hmm everybody's Gary Vaynerchuk haven't
done a garyvaynerchuk.com video in a
while first and foremost healthy and
happy Holidays to all you and your
family and the funding here at
vaynermedia and finally I'm going to
drop the bomb that needs to be dropped
and I'm the kind of guy to do it
once and for all let's talk about the
elephant room which is this this is
gonna hurt there's no such thing as
social media they could turn that off
its way through that I'm gonna say it
again there is no such thing as social
media I want to bring this the
discussion and put out in the forefront
social media is the term that we're
using to describe the current state of
the Internet when I hear social media I
hear like late teen years of a human
being go google right now you in quotes
YouTube web 2.0 site you'll see millions
of articles written about YouTube as a
web 2.0 site then go search YouTube as
YouTube social media site and you will
see millions of articles written about
YouTube as a social media site nothing
change what changes we needed a verb an
adjective and descriptor for the current
state of the Internet
so when you hear somebody talking about
what's the ROI of the of social media
that's basically like asking what's the
ROI of the Internet when you hear
somebody saying well I don't believe in
social media that's somebody saying I
don't believe in the Internet there is
no such thing as social media so you
mean it is a term to help us describe
the sites and I'll continue to use it
because it allows people to kind of
consume it but it is a word that is used
to describe the current sites Pinterest
and Tumblr and all these content sharing
sites now what are we gonna call it like
content 2.0 I mean there's going to be
another word
maybe mobile and one day it's gonna be
augmented or fantasy or gaming dynamic
3.0 there's always gonna be a word to
describe the current state of the
internet there's no such thing as social
media it's just a word to describe the
Internet and if you bet against the
Internet in 2012 you're gonna lose